The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOGDAN FEDELES: Hi, and welcome
to 5.07 Biochemistry Online,
the biochemistry course
on MIT OpenCourseWare.
I'm Dr. Bogdan Fedeles.
Let's metabolize some problems.
Now today we're going to
do a really nice problem.
This is Problem 1
in Problem Set 2.
Now, this is a problem
about elucidating
the primary structure
of a protein.
Problems like this one
that we're about to discuss
are a lot of fun because they're
really biochemistry puzzles.
We're given a number of
pieces of data or clues,
if you want, and then
we'd have to use,
not only our biochemical
sense, but also
deduction and elimination
process in order
to come up with a final answer.
Well, in practice, elucidating
the primary structure
of a protein is now a
largely automated process
and utilizes high resolution
mass spectrometry.
Some of the traditional
chemical methods
that we're discussing here
are still occasionally useful.
But most importantly, the
logical step-wise process
through which we analyze
and use each piece of data
to construct a
big picture result
is really representative of
the process by which we make
discoveries in biochemistry.
Before we begin, let me just
say that this problem assumes
familiarity with the structures
and abbreviations of the 20
natural amino acids.
Feel free to pause
this video and review
the relevant chapters in the
book and the lecture notes
before continuing.
One important tool that
we have for elucidating
the primary structure of
proteins is proteases.
Proteases are enzymes that can
hydrolyze the peptide bonds
of a polypeptide chain.
Now, proteases that can
cleave in the middle
of a polypeptide chain are
also called endopeptidases.
Now you notice a
lot of these names
that end in "ase" denote
enzymes, and peptidase
means an enzyme that
acts on a peptide.
It's the enzyme that
hydrolyzes the peptide bond.
Endo, in this case,
refers to the fact
that it acts in the middle
of a polypeptide chain.
Now, we're going to be learning
in this problem about trypsin
and chymotrypsin.
These are proteases that
cleave in the middle
of a polypeptide chain.
They are endopeptidases.
One important
feature of proteases
is that they are specific.
They don't just cut any which
one peptide bond, but rather
they recognize a specific
sequence of amino acids.
In the case of
trypsin, for example,
we are told that it cleaves
adjacent to positively
charged amino acid.
As you know, positively
charged amino acids
would be lysine or arginine.
So trypsin will
always be cutting
after arginine or lysine.
Let's take a look.
Now, here is a polypeptide
chain with amino acid residues,
R1, R2, R3, R4.
Now, let's look at
this peptide bond
right here in the
middle of the chain.
Now let's say in
order for trypsin
to cut, to hydrolyze
this peptide bond,
it means that R2, the amino
acid residue adjacent to it,
should be a positively
charged one.
So if R2 is lysine or
arginine, then this bond
here becomes a good
substrate for trypsin.
And what it's going to do, it's
going to use a water molecule--
it's going to put here trypsin--
and it's going to
hydrolyze forming
a carboxyl end and an amine
end of this peptide bond.
So we're getting this
is a carboxyl end
and this is the amine end of
that original peptide bond.
So what I want
you to remember is
that if we're having a
reaction with trypsin
on a polypeptide chain, then
the carboxy end of the peptide
that results, which is
this particular amino acid,
is going to be one of
either lysine or arginine.
So in other words
in a trypsin digest,
all the smaller
peptides that we obtain
are going to end in arginine
or lysine except, of course,
the very end of the
chain, which might
have a different amino
acid at its carboxyl end.
Now, this consideration we've
just made about the trypsin
digest, in fact, answers
part 1 of the problem, which
is asking what is common about
all these peptides generated
by a trypsin digest.
And as we've just explained,
all these peptides
should be ending with a
positively charged amino acid
such as lysine or arginine.
This problem also mentions
another protease chymotrypsin,
which is a protease that
has a different specificity
from trypsin.
It actually cleaves
after amino acids
that are either very hydrophobic
and large or aromatic.
So let's write that
down and remember.
So if we were to do a
digest with chymotrypsin,
then our R2, the residue that's
recognized by the protease,
is going to have to be either
aromatic, so phenylalanine,
tyrosine, or tryptophan,
or something that's
large and hydrophobic such
as leucine, isoleucine,
or even valine sometimes.
Put this in parentheses.
So if any of these residues
are at this position,
R2, then this
protease, chymotrypsin,
is going to generate
two peptides.
And once again, the resulting
peptide, R2 at the carboxy end
is going to be one
of these amino acids.
That's going to be the signature
of a chymotrypsin digest.
Now, keeping these
things in mind,
we're ready to tackle
the rest of the problem.
Question 2 asks about the use
of DTT, or dithiothreitol.
Now, DTT is a commonly
used reducing agent,
which can reduce disulfide
bridges in proteins.
There are many reasons
why we want to use DTT.
For example, when proteins
form disulfide bridges,
you may shield
certain amino acids
from being accessible
by proteases,
and therefore, they're
not going to be cleaved
and we'll get a
mixture of peptides.
So it makes our analysis and
our results very difficult.
Now, disulfide bridges can
also hold two peptides together
that have no other covalent
attachment between them.
So in that case,
we get one fragment
instead of two fragments, and
once again, it complicates
our analysis of the protein.
But more importantly,
because we're typically
purifying proteins in the
air, in an oxygen atmosphere,
proteins can acquire disulfide
bonds, which weren't there
in the beginning.
So in that case, we can
get very unusual results,
unreproducible and artefactual.
That's why using DTT can prevent
formation of spurious disulfide
bridges.
And finally, DTT is
also useful to tell
if there were any disulfide
bridges in the protein
to begin with.
Because if we're
looking at the analysis
before and after using DTT, we
can tell if the results change,
and that will tell us whether
disulfide bridges were there
to begin with.
Now, let's take a look
at the DTT chemistry.
Here we have a disulfide
bond or bridge in a protein,
and we're going to
treat this with DTT,
which looks like this.
This is DTT or dithiothreitol.
Now, if we substitute the
SH groups with OH's, you
notice we're going to have
four OH's and four carbons.
That's just an alcohol
derived from a sugar, which
is called threose That's why
the threitol part of the name.
All right.
So when we do this
chemical reaction,
this disulfide bridge is going
to transfer between the two
sulfur atoms of DTT.
They're going to form a
intramolecular sulfide bond.
So our cysteines are
going to get reduced,
and from DTT, we're going to
get this intramolecular sulfide.
And because entropical
considerations,
make the formation
of the six-member
ring very, very easy, then
this equilibrium will typically
shift to the right.
Of course, we're also using
vast quantities of DTT
to make sure that the entire
protein becomes reduced,
and then our agent is going
to pick up this [INAUDIBLE]
off the bond.
This sums up the question
2 of the problem.
Next, we're going to
look at distinguishing
between a couple of
different peptides
that we generate during
our analysis of our mystery
protein.
So we're told that we're
isolating by HPLC peptides
of the following composition.
One has tryptophan,
phenylalanine,
valine, aspartate,
lysine, cysteine.
That's peptide one.
Another one has phenylalanine,
serine, cysteine,
and an unknown amino acid.
Finally, the third one
has alanine and lysine.
All right.
Now, obviously, these peptides
have different compositions,
so if you could just put them
through mass spectrometry,
we're going to get
different masses,
so we can tell very
quickly which one is which.
But if we don't have
mass spec available,
we can also tell them apart
only using UV-Vis spectroscopy.
So all you need to remember
is that an amino acid
like tryptophan
that we have here,
W, has a very strong absorption
in the 280 to 300 nanometers.
Whereas, amino acids
like phenylalanine,
present here or here, they
absorb only around 260
nanometers.
Most of the other amino acids
don't absorb in this range
at all.
So if we were to plot the UV-Vis
spectra of these peptides,
this is going to
be our absorption,
and this is going to be lambda
in nanometers, the wavelength.
So let's look in the
range from 200 to 400.
300 is about here.
250 is about here.
And let's label these.
Let's say this peptide is
red, this peptide is blue,
and this one is green.
All right.
So now the red
peptide, as I told you,
contains both tryptophan
and phenylalanine,
so it's going to
absorb both around 260
and both around 280 to 300.
So it's going to have a
pretty big hump in this area
from 250 to 300.
Now, the blue peptide
only has phenylalanine,
so above 280 or so, nanometer
is going to drop off.
So it's going to
look more like this,
whereas, the green one, well,
it has neither phenylalanine
or tryptophan, so
below 240 or so,
it's going to have no
UV absorption at all.
So it's going to
drop off right here.
So basically, if
we're just looking,
say, around 260 nanometers,
we should see a stronger peak
from the red peptide and a
weaker peak from the blue one.
But if we're going
to look around 300,
we should only see
the red peptide.
So by just using the
UV-Vis absorption,
we can tell these
three peptides apart.
Now we're ready to figure out
the structure of our mystery
protein.
This is exactly what the last
part of the problem is asking.
So we're going to take each
one of the clues provided--
A, B, C, and D--
and analyze and see
what information we can
derive from each one of them.
The first piece of
information that we're given
is the result of
a total hydrolysis
of our peptide
with six molar HCl.
So we're told we get
the following amino acid
composition.
We get two phenylalanines, one
methionine, alanine, valine,
two lysines, one serine, two
cysteine, and one aspartate.
Now, recall this is not
a comprehensive list
because the hydrolysis
and six smaller HCl
may destroy some
of the amino acids.
And specifically, we
know for sure something
like tryptophan,
threonine, and tyrosine.
They're going to be
destroyed, and we're not
going to see them here.
So these amino acids may still
be present in our protein,
but we're not going to be able
to see them in this situation.
Now, let's analyze
these amino acids
and see what we can
derive from this.
So first of all,
we have cysteines.
So two cysteines,
it means our protein
can form disulfide bridges.
So from the get
go, two cysteine,
it means we can form an
internal disulfide bridge
or our protein contains a
disulfide bridge between two
otherwise unconnected peptides.
So here are some possibilities.
For example, our
peptide is one chain,
and our cysteines are
not actually connected
by a disulfide bridge.
Another possibility is we
do have a disulfide bridge
between them, like that.
Or yet another possibility is
that we have two pieces, two
polypeptide chains, and
the disulfide bridge
is the only thing that's
holding them together.
Now, in each one of
these cases, obviously,
these polypeptide
chains are oriented.
So in one end, they're going
to have the amine group.
Let me draw it here, NH3.
Here we're going to have
two, and the other end
is going to be the
carboxyl group, COO minus.
And once again, in
this case, we're
going to have two of them.
All right.
Now, how can we narrow down from
these couple of possibilities?
Well, the fact that we're
getting two lysines here
is a very important clue.
Now remember, we're told that
our peptide, this mystery
protein, it actually comes as
a result of a trypsin digest.
And if you recall our
discussion earlier,
we said that upon
trypsin digest,
all the smaller peptides
that were obtained
will end in lysine
or an arginine.
The fact that we have
two lysines here,
it means both of
them they need to be
at the carboxy ends of peptides.
Because if they were in
the middle of a chain,
the trypsin would have
cut that chain in half.
So two lysines means we've
got to have two carboxy ends.
So therefore, this seems to be
the only possibility in which
we can accommodate two lysines.
Basically, the two carboxy
ends that we see here,
each one has to be a lysine.
This possibility only
has one carboxy end,
so the other lysine
that we have to place
will not be at the
end, so would not
be compatible with
a trypsin digest.
Same applies for this case.
So these possibilities are
not consistent with our data.
So we know already
that our protein must
look like this, two
polypeptide chains,
each one ends with
lysine, and there
must be a disulfide bridge.
The second clue we're given
is that the Edman degradation
of the protein yields valine.
Now, as you know,
Edman degradation
is a chemical reaction by
which we can digest the protein
from the N terminus,
from the amino terminus
of a polypeptide chain.
Now as you recall, we have
established in the first part
that we have two amino
termini in our protein.
So the fact that we only get one
amino acid and that is valine,
it says that the
other amino terminus
might be blocked or
somehow unavailable
for the Edman degradation.
So let's update the
structure of our protein
to take into account
the second clue.
So we said we have two
polypeptide chains.
There's a disulfide
bond in between them.
Now, each one of them
ends with a lysine.
This is a carboxy
end, and now we
know from the Edman degradation
that amino end of one of them
has to be valine.
The other one-- we're going
to put a box like that--
is a blocked end.
So the amino terminus
is not available.
So this is as much as we can
tell from these first two
clues.
We're given the products
of the chymotrypsin
digest of our protein
after it was previously
treated with DTT.
So we know first DTT is going
to cleave the disulfide bond,
and then chymotrypsin,
as we talked previously,
is going to cut after large,
hydrophobic, or aromatic
amino acids.
Now, we're told we're getting
five smaller peptides.
Let's take a look.
Here are the five fragments.
One is tryptophan, valine; one
is cysteine, phenylalanine,
another one is aspartate
lysine, another one
is methionine, alanine,
cysteine, and lysine;
and finally, the last one
has serine, phenylalanine,
and something that's
not an amino acid.
It's going to make
it like a small x.
All right.
Now, from what we know
about chymotrypsin digest,
we should be able to orient
these peptides basically
to tell which amino acid
is at the N terminus
and which amino acid is at the
C terminus of each one of them.
Now the first one.
Well, we know from
the second clue
that valine is at
the N terminus,
so that makes it pretty easy.
Then the sequence has to be V-W.
So valine is the N terminus,
W is the C terminus,
and as we said,
tryptophan is one of the
amino acids recognized
by chymotrypsin, so
it's going to end up
at the carboxy terminus.
C-F, that has to go C
and F, phenylalanine,
another chymotrypsin
amino acid that's
left of this carboxy terminus.
D-K. Now, neither
of these amino acids
is recognized by chymotrypsin,
but we remember from clue one
that D-K must be the
carboxy terminus.
So the sequence can only be D-K.
Now, here M, A, C,
and K, none of these
is actually on our recognition
list for chymotrypsin,
but once again, we know that
K must be in the carboxy end.
So for now we're
going to have M, A,
and C in a particular order,
which we cannot establish just
yet and K at the carboxy end.
And finally, we
do an S, F and x.
Well, x is not
even an amino acid,
and F is an amino acid that's
left of the carboxy terminus
by chymotrypsin, so it's
probably x, S, and F. Now,
what about x?
We're told that x is not an
amino acid and is hydrophobic
and it has a molecular
weight of 256 Daltons.
All right.
So in order to
figure out what x is,
we have to read back the
beginning of the problem, which
tells us that we're looking
at a protein that's associated
with a plasma membrane.
And one way for proteins
to associate with a plasma
membrane is to be modified,
to incorporate a fatty acid,
such as palmitate.
So perhaps x, which is blocking
the N terminus of this peptide
is a fatty acid.
Now, the general
formula for fatty acids
is something like this,
CH3 CH2 repeated, say,
n times, and then COOH.
So let's see what would
be the fatty acid that
has the molecular
weight 256 Daltons?
Well, the mass of a
methyl group is 15.
The mass of this carboxylate
is 45, so we have about 60
plus 14n equals 256
or 14n equals 196.
Therefore, n is 14.
So the fatty acid that
would fit these criteria--
it's hydrophobic, it
has a mass of 256--
will be CH3, CH2 14 times
COOH, or the fatty acid
was 16 carbons.
This is palmitic acid.
Now, the answer that
we got, palmitic acid,
was anticipated in the
text of the problem
because it gave us an example
one way to associate proteins
to the plasma
membrane is to form
a covalent linkage with a
fatty acid such as palmitate.
But how does a protein
associate with a plasma
membrane when it has a palmitic
acid residue as part of it?
Well, let's take a
look at a diagram.
Here we have a representation
of the plasma membrane,
where we have the phospholipids
like the hydrophilic head
pointing inside and outside the
cell and the hydrophobic tails
of the fatty acids
lined up to each other.
Now, imagine we have
a protein that's
modified to contain one
of these fatty acids.
Then this fatty acid can
just insert right next
to the phospholipids
of the plasma membrane.
And that way it tethers
the protein right
at the plasma membrane.
The final clue that we're
given in order to figure out
the structure of
our mystery protein
is the digest with an
inorganic agent this time.
It's called cyanogen bromide.
Cyanogen bromide reacts quite
specifically with methionines,
and it cleaves the peptide
bond after methionine
leaving behind an
unnatural amino acid called
a homoserine lactone.
Now, let's take a
look at what happens
when we treat our protein
with cyanogen bromide.
So we're told we're getting
the following peptides, A, K
and W, F, V, D, K, C and F, S,
C, and an unnatural amino acid.
As I just explained to you, the
unnatural amino acid probably
is this homoserine lactone.
So it's most likely,
instead of this amino acid
in the actual sequence,
we had a methionine.
So we know these four residues--
F, S, C, and M--
go together.
All right.
Now, we can start putting
together the clues
from part 3 and 4 and try to
figure out the final structure
of our protein.
So the peptide A, K, we know
has to have K at the C terminus.
Now, from part 3, we
found out that there
was a peptide that
contained M, A, C, and K,
after the chymotrypsin digest.
So now we know K has
to be the carboxy end
and A has to be right
before K, so in order
to get an A-K
peptide, then A has
to be right after
methionine because that's
where cyanogen bromide is going
to cleave the peptide bond.
So the only sequence
that we can have here is
going to be C followed
by M followed by A
followed by K. So when we
treat the cyanogen bromide,
we're going to be cleaving
this bond between M and A,
generating M as a
homoserine lactone.
Now, we also know that M has
to be in this small peptide,
and we know it has to
be C, M as a sequence.
So therefore, S and F have
to be on the amino terminus
of this peptide.
And we also have a
clue from part 3, which
said that S, F, and this
non amino acid moiety
were in the same peptide.
So from here we said that,
well, the sequence there, it's
probably x modifying the amino
S and then F with a carboxy end.
So putting these
three things together,
we can come up with a sequence
for this strand, which
is going to be x, S,
F, then C, M and then A
and K. So this is probably
one of the peptide chains
in our mystery protein.
Then, of course,
the other is going
to be composed of
these amino acids.
Now, we already know something
about the sequence of these.
For example, we know V
goes before W. We also
know D goes before K, and also
know C goes before F. Now, we
know this has to be the carboxy
end of the peptide chain.
Let's write it here, COO minus.
And V has to be the amino end.
So then C-F, there's no other
way, has to be in the middle.
So the only possible
sequence for our second chain
is going to be V,
W, C, F, D, and K.
Now that we've established
the exact sequence
of each one of these
peptide chains,
then we can put together
the final structure
of our mystery protein.
So I'm going to transcribe these
here, the first chain V, W, C,
F, D, and K. And we know
the cysteine is going
to have our disulfide bridge
to the other cysteine, which
goes C, M, A, K, and
then F, and then S.
And now we know the N
terminus of this peptide,
we're going to have our fatty
acid residue CH2 14 times CH3.
So let's just mark, once
again, the carboxy ends here
and the amino end here.
So this is the final
answer for our problem
and the structure of
our mystery peptide.
Well, that's it
for this problem.
I hope you enjoyed this
little protein mystery hunt.
Now, remember that the
strategy that we used here
in which we logically string
together pieces of data
to build a big picture, it's
really the same strategy
that has been used and is
being used right now to advance
our knowledge about living
systems and their underlying
biochemistry.te equations.
What I'm going to
do is just show you
a picture of how
this theory helps
us think about these
catalytic transformations
and then how this picture helps
us think more specifically
about these amazing
rate accelerations
that we actually observe.
OK, so I can't remember
what's on the next slide,
but this is a picture
you often see when you're
thinking about catalysis.
So this is chemical catalysis,
but again, chemical catalysis,
biological catalysis, really
the same basic principles
hold that we have
some substrates A
and B going to products
and what's required.
So I think all of
this is intuitive,
but if you have two
things coming together,
they have to come together
in exactly the right way
to be able to make a bond.
They have to remove all the
solvent from outside them.
They have to come
together with enough force
to be able to get over the
barrier, whatever it is,
to break one bond and
to form a new bond.
So that's true of all
reactions and everybody faces
the same issues in terms
of conversion of substrate
into products.
And the highest point
along the reaction
coordinate-- so
this is what we call
a reaction coordinate diagram.
And this is energy.
So the highest point along the
reaction coordinate diagram
is called the
transition state-- TS.
This is transition state theory.
OK, TS theory.
And this is where-- this is
the point where we can ever
isolate it because
this is a point where
all the chemistry is happening.
The bonds are being
made and broken.
And the lifetime I just showed
you on the previous slide
is fast-- fentaseconds.
So you can never isolate
a transition state.
Everything needs to be aligned.
That doesn't come
free of charge.
You have to do a lot of
work to get to the stage
where you can get this
chemistry to happen.
That's what our
catalysts are doing.
And then bang, the reaction
is over at that time.
So this is another way of
describing the transition
state of the reaction.
And in reality,
this is the cartoon
you see in most introductory
textbooks that are describing
rates of reaction.
But the reaction coordinate is
much, much more complicated.
And that's true in
enzymatic reactions as well.
So it's true of
chemical reactions,
it's true enzymatic reactions.
So you might have
a plus b, and they
might form two or
three intermediates
along the reaction
pathway where you
have many transitions-- you
have many transition states
along the reaction pathway.
And each of these transitions
states would be non-isolable.
But what about these
little valleys?
These little valleys are
where you might have a chance
to see an intermediate during
the conversion of a plus
b into p plus q.
So an intermediate--
and if you're
interested in studying
catalysis and the chemistry
of the reaction and
you need to define
what these intermediates
are, they can be high
or that could be
lower in energy.
They may be easy to isolate,
not easy to isolate.
But they have all
covalent bonds intact.
So in contrast to the
transition state where
the bonds are being
made and broken,
you can never isolate this.
You have a chance to be able--
if you're clever and creative,
which people that
study mechanisms are,
you can actually look
at the intermediates
along the reaction coordinate.
So that's a reaction
coordinate diagram.
We're going to
come back to these
because I think they really help
us to conceptualize how enzymes
can go about achieving these
fantastic rate accelerations.
So from transition
state theory, one
assumes the following--
I'm not going
to go through the
details of this at all.
But the key point that
one needs to think about
in transition state
theory is that--
and this was first put
forth by Linus Pauling.
Who's Linus Pauling?
He's my hero.
OK, Linus Pauling,
he's the vitamin C guy.
He lost it when he got
old, but in the early days,
he's the one that could take
a polypeptide chain-- just
a string of amino
acids-- and he sat there
and he played with it.
And lo and behold,
he says, we're
going to have alpha
helices in proteins.
How amazing is that?
You've heard me talk
about him before.
He was the one that I think
conceptualized-- first
conceptualized-- how an enzyme
might catalyze a reaction.
What do you want to do
to catalyze a reaction?
You want to lower this barrier.
So how do you lower the barrier?
You don't want the enzyme to
bind the substrates tightly,
and I'll come back
to this in a minute.
You want to bind the
transition state tightly.
So he put forth in the
1940s that the way enzymes
might be able to catalyze
their reactions is
by tightly binding--
uniquely and tightly binding
the transition state
of the reaction.
And I think that turns out
to be a really good way
to conceptualize most
enzymatic reactions.
Now, transition
state theory tells
us, which again is
not so appealing to me
but it works to describe
most experimental data,
that the ground state-- so this
would be the ground state--
is in equilibrium with
the transition state.
So you might ask
yourself, how the heck
can you ever be in
equilibrium with something
with such a short half life?
That's a good question to ask.
But in fact, this framework--
transition state theory--
allows us to able
to explain almost
all the experimental
observations
that we make as both
chemists and biochemists.
So this goes through and
derives that equation, which
I'm not going to do today.
In the old days, I used
to spend a lot of time
deriving equations.
Nowadays, I don't derive
equations anymore.
But the key equation that
you need to think about
is shown here.
And the consequences of this
equation are quite simple.
It tells you that the rate
constant for the reaction-- so
from transition state
theory, the rate
constant for the reaction.
And where is this rate constant?
Where does this rate
constant come from?
A is going to some product p.
You can measure
it experimentally.
So k observed is an
experimentally measurable
parameter is equal to a
bunch of constants called
the transmission coefficient.
This should be a cappa.
Boltzmann's
constant, temperature
in degrees Kelvin,
Planck's constant times
e to the minus delta
g dagger over rg.
So this is the equation.
This is a constant.
This is Planck's constant,
Boltzmann's constant.
This you can measure
experimentally.
Cappa is telling you basically--
the transmission coefficient
is telling you the frequency
that this transition state
breaks down to form
products versus going back
to starting materials and in
general, is on the order of one
in most reactions.
And so the key thing to remember
from this equation, which
explains the data and helps
us to think about catalysis,
is that as you increase
the rate of the reaction,
it's inversely related to
the activation barrier.
So what you want to do,
this equation tells you,
is you lower this barrier.
The rate of your reaction
becomes faster and faster.
So the whole goal is,
then, to figure out
how to lower the barrier.
If you can lower the
barrier, this theory
predicts that the rate of
your reaction will be faster.
So that's what we
want to be able to do.
The rate constant
is inversely related
to the activation barrier.
And so now let's look at an
enzyme system specifically.
So I'm going to draw the
same kind of reaction
coordinate that we've drawn over
there for a chemical reaction.
And I'm going to use
a simple equation.
E is the enzyme, s is
the substrate forms
an enzyme substrate complex.
The substrate
binds in the region
that we call the
active site over here.
Somehow, the enzyme is able to
convert itself into product.
Now, most reactions are much
more complicated than this.
You have many substrates.
You have many products.
But it doesn't affect
anything in terms
of thinking about the problem.
And then in the end,
the product dissociates.
So that's a simple reaction.
You get something in there,
a catalyst works on it,
it gets converted to
the desired product,
and the product is released.
So what I've told you
now a couple of times
is that enzymes have
evolved to such an extent
that often the physical
steps and not the chemistry
is rate limiting.
So what are the physical steps?
Here are the physical steps.
Enzyme finding
substrate and solution,
that's a physical step.
What is limited by?
It's limited by
diffusion control.
How fast can they find
each other in solution?
That's the number 10
to the 8 per molar
per second that limits most
enzyme-based reactions that I
showed you several slides ago.
What about this?
We have product dissociation.
What about product dissociation?
That's a physical step too.
You made the product
sitting around,
but in order for the
enzyme to turn over, again,
to free up the active
site, the product
has to come off so it can
bind another substrate.
And here is the chemistry.
Ah, that's what I care about.
But what happens, now, is
that if these steps are
rate limiting, then you
can't see the chemistry.
So it's really challenging,
often really challenging,
to study the chemistry
of a reaction
because the rate limiting
steps have nothing
to do with the chemistry.
So let me just draw a diagram.
So you can draw a reaction
coordinate diagram.
And so what you have is
some enzyme plus substrate
and it can form an
enzyme substrate complex.
You have a transition
state of your reaction.
The enzyme product
complex can then
dissociate to form
enzyme plus product.
So what you need to
think about if you're
thinking about how to
accelerate the reaction is
what is the bottleneck
in the overall reaction?
You don't want to
start mucking around
with something that
doesn't control
the rate of the reaction.
So you need to know what
the rate limiting step
is in the reaction.
And the rate limiting step
is the highest barrier
along the reaction coordinate.
OK, now I've already told you
that this is a simple case.
We have one substrate getting
converted into product.
Most enzymatic reactions are
going to have many barriers.
And so in order to affect the
overall rate of the reaction,
you need to figure out
what's rate limiting,
and somehow the
enzyme has figured out
how to lower the barrier to make
this reaction easier to occur.
Remember, I just told you that
the rate constant is inversely
related to this
activation barrier.
So if we can lower
this barrier somehow,
what we're going to see, if
we can lower this barrier,
now we have a lower overall
rate of the reaction.
So this theory
allows us to think
about what we need to do to
make these catalysts actually
work with rate constants of
10 to 6 to 10 to 15 times
faster than
non-catalyzed reactions.
And I want to say one other
thing before you move on.
As with everything,
I think it's good
that we're in a field
that's rapidly changing.
Remember, I told you have
to think about dynamics.
We no longer think about
a single reaction barrier.
That's in most of
the textbooks now.
Really what we think about is
we bring dynamics into this.
I told you things
outside the active site
can modulate what's going
on inside the active site.
What we think about is
a reaction landscape.
And so one has many barriers
that one has to get over.
Almost all reactions
involve multiple barriers.
So you've got to figure out
which one is rate limiting
and lower that
activation barrier.
And enzymes, if you think
about this, they're huge.
Do they all fold
exactly the same way?
No.
So we always think we
have a homogeneous enzyme.
No.
If any of you work
in UROPs, you'll
find that out pretty fast.
You use recombinant technology
to fold things inside the cell.
They don't all fold right.
So you have all
mixtures of things.
And so you get a
reaction landscape.
And so this axis is
bringing in the dynamics
that I told you about
earlier on that you
need to think about-- the
conformational changes that
occur every step along
the reaction pathway.
The enzyme is moving
at all kinds of steps,
reorienting everything to get
the chemistry exactly right.
So what I want to do now
is-- so that gives you
a way to conceptualize
rate accelerations.
Now what I want
to do is tell you
what the major mechanisms are
that the enzyme uses to enhance
the rates of these reactions.
How do we lower these
energy barriers?
So let me see.
I need to start
erasing somewhere.
OK, so we're on the
third bullet over here.
Mechanisms of catalysis.
And what we're going
to be talking about
is multiple mechanisms
of catalysis.
We're going to be talking
about binding energy, which
is the one people have most
trouble thinking about.
We're going to be talking about
general acid, general base
catalysis.
And we're going to be talking
about covalent catalysis.
And we will see
that over the course
of the rest of
the semester, when
we start talking about
metabolic pathways,
all of these mechanisms
are used in almost
all enzyme catalyzed
reactions to give us
these tremendous
rate accelerations.
What I want to do-- that's
the first time I did that.
That wasn't too bad.
OK, so what are the
mechanisms of catalysis?
How do we get 10 to the 6 to
10 to the 15 accelerations?
And so the first
thing, and I think
the one that really is unique
to enzyme catalysts compared
to small inorganic
or organic molecules,
is the use of binding
energy in catalysis.
So this is the one--
and this is also
the one that's thought to
contribute the greatest
amount to these factors
of up to 10 to 15.
So binding energy in catalysis,
and what does that mean?
What do we need to think about?
So the enzyme binds
to a substrate.
If we take this simple
case, we need it to bind.
We need it to bind specifically.
So that's a key
part of the enzyme
that we haven't gotten
to yet-- specificity.
But what if it bound its
substrate really tightly?
Do you think that would be good?
No.
So it's not good
because what does it do?
If it took all of the spinach
changing off of your substrate
and made hydrogen bonds and
Van Der Waals interactions,
all the weak
non-covalent interactions
we spent a half
a lecture talking
about four or five lectures
ago, what would happen is you
would have type binding.
You would have lower energy.
But what does that then do
to the activation barrier?
It increases the
activation barrier.
So the binding energy is the
free energy released when
enzyme combines with substrate.
But the key is that
this bind energy is not
used to bind completely.
It's used for catalysis.
So this energy is used
both to bind substrate
and-- and this is the key
thing-- for catalysis.
So what do we want to be able
to do and how does it do this?
So if we look at this, if
we look at our reaction
coordinate diagram over here,
we don't want to bind substrate
tightly because this is the
biggest barrier-- the rate
limiting step along
the reaction pathway.
What we want to do is
lower this barrier.
So how can we lower the barrier?
We can lower the barrier by
stabilizing the transition
state.
That now makes this
barrier-- probably
can't read anything now, but
that makes this barrier lower.
How's another way you
could lower the barrier?
You could lower the barrier
by straining the substrate
to look more like
the transition state.
So you could strain the
substrate in this form,
and now, again, you would
have a lower barrier compared
to that barrier.
So you're going to use this
binding energy to stabilize
a transition state.
So we want to use binding energy
to stabilize the transition
state to de-stabilize-- any
of these or all of these
could be true-- de-stabilize
the ground state-- G-S.
Or what else do you need
to do to get a reaction
to work if you have one or
two substrates or even one
substrate?
Your molecules in
solution are all solvated.
What you need to be able to
do is get rid of the solvent.
If you have two substrates, you
have to bring them together.
You have to bring them together
at the right orientation.
That doesn't come
free of charge.
You have to get the
energy from somewhere,
and the energy is proposed to
come from this binding energy.
So the binding
energy is not used
to completely bind
the substrate,
but to do all of these
things to get your substrates
ready to form product.
So you can dissolvate and
bring reactants together.
And you can freeze out
rotational, translational
entropy.
So you're getting everything
ready for the reaction
to happen.
So in this case, then, let me
just erase this and make this
so that this is clearer.
What you could have, now, is
you can-- so in the beginning,
this is the barrier.
If you stabilize the transition
state, this becomes a barrier.
If you de-stabilize
the ground state,
then this becomes the barrier.
So what we're trying to
do is lower this barrier
to get the reaction to work.
And so the major
way that we do this
is by using the interactions
between the enzymes
of the weak non-covalent
interactions between the enzyme
and substrate to help
us do these things
to enhance catalysis.
So that's one of the major
mechanisms of catalysis.
A second-- and this
type of catalysis
is unique to proteins.
So the two types of
catalysis are used widely
in organic or
inorganic chemistry
when you're designing
your catalyst.
I mean, when you're designing
a catalyst substrate binding,
a small molecule, a big product
release is still an issue.
If you go and read the
organometallic literature,
people have trouble with
product release all the time.
So the issues in catalysis
are exactly the same
in biochemistry as they are
in organic and inorganic.
But now we have to deal
with this big protein, which
has these unique
properties, one of which
is that the whole protein is
playing a key role in catalysis
and allowing everything to
align within tenths of angstroms
to make these reactions work
really efficiently, which
chemists can't do yet.
And I don't think we'll
ever be able to design it,
but we can evolve catalysts
to become better and better
so that they can
do the same thing.
That's the beauty of proteins
is you can evolve them to become
better and better catalysts.
So the second mechanism--
so the first mechanism
is binding energy.
The second mechanism-- I can't
remember whether they're using
I's or 2's.
The second mechanism is general
acid, general base catalysis.
Now, as a chemist,
what do you learn
about catalyzing reactions?
Well, one way you could do
it is with a big fat proton.
Protons are pretty good at
helping you catalyze reactions
if you go back and think
about chemical transformations
or hydroxide ions.
What are the concentration
of protons and hydroxide ions
in aqueous solution of pH 7?
10 to the minus 7 molar.
So you don't have much
protons and hydroxide
ions in the active site.
So even though these
are very good catalysts
that organic chemists
and inorganic chemists
use all the time, they're
using them in organic solvents,
you can argue the active
site of the enzyme
is more like an organic solvent.
But anyhow, this type of
catalysis is called specific.
So when you see specific
acid or based catalysis--
where does the general acid
and base catalysis come from?
It comes from the side
chain of your amino acids.
So remember, the second
or third lecture I said,
oh, here are all
the amino acids.
Here are all the side chains.
You really shouldn't know
all of your amino acids.
It's a basic vocabulary
of all of biochemistry,
and the pKas of all
the side chains.
Why?
That's why.
Because you can't understand
anything about catalysis
without knowing what these
side chains of the enzymes
are actually doing.
So the general acid
and base catalysis
come from the side chains
of your amino acids.
So what side chains do you have?
You can have carboxylates.
Anybody know what the
pKa of a carboxylate is?
Hey, Boggin, what is it?
STUDENT: Four to five.
JOANNE STUBBE:
Good, four to five.
See, he remembers.
You could have imidazole.
This has a pKa at neutral pH.
Anyhow, you need
to go back and look
at what the groups are that
can be involved in catalysis.
And chemists, for
decades, have studied
how you can use general
acid and base catalysis
to give you rate enhancements.
Now, what I haven't told you is
the amount of rate enhancement
And so people over the
years have measured
that with binding energy, you
can get factors of 10 to the 8.
If you look at general acid
base catalysis from all
the organic and
inorganic reactions
people have studied for decades,
you get factors of 100 to 1,000
fold.
Now, we need to get to a factor
of 10 to the 15 in some cases.
We've already gotten to
the factor of 10 to 6.
So obviously,
you're going to have
to use multiple combinations
of these mechanisms
to give you these tremendous
rate accelerations.
So you will see over the course
of the rest of the semester
many active sites of enzymes
with many amino acid side
chains that are playing roles
in general acid and base
catalysis.
And the last type of catalysis
is covalent catalysis.
And again, covalent catalysis
means that you form--
and where have you already
seen covalent catalysis?
You've already seen this
when we talked about, how
do you study the structure
of the primary structure
of a protein?
We use proteases with
tripsin or kimotripsan
that can break down the big
protein into small pieces.
We went through the
mechanism of that reaction.
In the active site
of that enzyme,
there is a serine that
forms a covalent bond.
So over the course
of the semester,
you're going to
see many examples.
And I'll just put in
parentheses for those of you
who don't remember, go back
and look at serine proteases.
This is a classic example
that's in every textbook.
And how do we know how
much rate acceleration
you get from covalent
catalysis versus not having
covalent catalysis.
We know this, again, because
of organic chemists studying
the detailed chemical
mechanisms of these reactions,
and we find out
that in this case,
we get rate accelerations
of 100 to 1,000 fold.
So what you see is the enzymes.
And these are the three
general mechanisms
by which all enzymes
catalyze their reactions
in some variation.
Now, attributing out of
this 10 to 15, 10 to the 8
is associated with
this, and 10 squared
is associated with that
is extremely challenging.
And there are a lot
of people still trying
to dissect reaction
mechanisms in detail.
And I would argue
that understanding
how these different methods
work and synergize to give you
these accelerations is a
key to eventually designing
new catalysts that
can do what you
want them to do that's
distinct from biological
transformations.
And I think I'm probably over.
I just want to say
one more thing.
I just want to
give you a feeling
for what you have to do.
If you're thinking about this
reaction coordinate, what
you need to do is think
about how would you
stabilize the transition state
relative to the ground state?
So what we're talking
about is stabilization
that's unique to the transition
state and not the ground state.
If you stabilized them
both, what would happen?
If you stabilized them both--
if you stabilize this guy
and you stabilize
this guy, the barrier
would be exactly the same.
So what you need is some
way to uniquely stabilize
the transition state
over the ground state.
So the question is,
how much do you think?
How much rate
acceleration do you
think you can get
from a hydrogen bond?
Does anybody have any idea?
One hydrogen bond.
So here, you have a protein
with 1,500 hydrogen bonds.
But if you can get one
hydrogen bond that's
here in the transition
state of the reaction,
that's not over here, how
much rate acceleration
do you think you can get?
Anybody got any idea?
You can get almost 1,000 fold.
I mean, and you can do a
very simple calculation.
I can't remember whether I have
this on the-- OK, so that's it.
So we can do a very
simple calculation,
and I'll use this to
show you the calculation.
Here, we have our rate.
This should be Delta G. The
dagger should be up in the air.
So this is the
enzymatic reaction.
This is the
[INAUDIBLE] equation.
One has the same equation
for non-enzymatic reactions.
So here's a
non-enzymatic reaction.
In general, the
non-enzymatic reaction
can happen by some mechanism.
To the enzymatic reaction
is just much, much slower.
So if we assume, for example,
that the rate difference
between enzymatic and a
non-enzymatic reaction
is a factor of 10,
how much do you
get assuming that
all of these terms
are the same in the enzymatic
and the non-enzymatic reaction?
You can calculate a
Delta Delta G dagger
of 1.38 kilocalories per mole.
For those of you
who are modern, this
is 5.8 kilojoules per mole.
Sorry, I'm really
old, so I still
think in kilocalories per mole.
But a hydrogen bond, one
hydrogen bond is worth 2 to 7--
compared to no hydrogen
bond, is worth 2
to 7 kilocalories per mole.
So a factor of 10 is 1.4
kilocalories per mole.
So that shows you, then,
that if you had 2 to 7
with one hydrogen
bond, it can give you
these factors of 1,000.
So I think that's an
observation that's
something you need to keep
in the back of your mind.
Because you think about
it over and over again.
It really doesn't take
much to align everything
in exactly the right way.
And when I say hydrogen bond,
these hydrogen bond strengths
are really dependent on
how everything is aligned.
If they're exactly aligned, then
you get much stronger bonds.
They can even approach--
in the gas phase,
they could approach 30
kilocalories per mole.
So having everything
aligned, that's
the job of this
whole big protein,
to actually give you catalysis.
And I think I'm at the
end of my lecture now.
I won't have time to talk
about-- I went over already
about the question
of specificity.
But let me just say, I
think enzymes are really
quite amazing.
There's nothing like them.
Faster than a speeding bullet.
They can catalyze the rates
a million to 10 to the 12, 10
to the 15-fold.
And they use really
the simple concepts
that chemists have
developed over the years.
But the key to the enzyme
is this big huge molecule,
and the dynamics within this
molecule that gets everything
to align exactly right to be
able to lower these barriers so
that you can convert your
substrate into your product.
OK guys, see you next time.
The end.